judy faulkner is one of the most
successful
self-made women that you've probably
never heard of
her company is called epic systems and
it is based in verona wisconsin
epic systems is a company that does
electronic health records
which might not sound all that exciting
what the company does
really is basically like the backbone
of a hospital and
the way that you would interact with it
is so you call your doctor you go online
and you make an appointment
that appointment scheduling is through
the electronic health record then when
you actually go visit your doctor
and they figure out what's wrong with
you you get a prescription
that also goes in there there are about
225 million people in the united states
with
an electronic health record in epic
faulkner has been building epic since
1979.
i didn't intend at all to to have
this career i happened to write the
original software and everybody asked me
to start a company and i kept saying no
until i finally said yes she created
this system
and it was basically just a really fast
and easy way to
create a schedule that otherwise would
have taken an extremely long time and a
lot of people to do it
she started building a database
that and this was really really
innovative at the time you could
actually track a patient's record
over time from when you know the first
time that they went to see the doctor
two the next time that they went to see
the doctor as the company grew
it added things like billing it
um it got a nicer user interface
so and it was being used at outpatient
clinics and then inpatient hospitals
around 2009 the government
started to get involved by really
encouraging hospitals to adopt these
electronic health records
then there was legislation passed and
hospitals
uh all of a sudden had a reason and they
had funding to
really increase adoption and um
epic it was really it was reliable
today around 2 400 hospitals worldwide
are using epic
since epic's founding in 1979 faulkner
has rejected outside investors
wall street financing and acquisitions
but that's also
where epic gets criticized because
people say that that kind of build it
alone mentality
means that it's difficult to
share data during the pandemic epic
system stepped up to help
judy and epic made a decision that
they wouldn't charge their customers for
code 19 related software so this was
like infection control software
for all these pop-up hospitals that were
starting to be built
many other pop-up hospitals like at the
javits center
and still they're no longer charging
customers
for those uh that kind of software
and judy said there was like 500 million
dollars in foregone revenue that they
didn't take in because they gave
they gave away all that stuff for free
forbes estimates faulkner's 47
stake in epic to be worth 6 billion
which makes her the second richest
self-made woman in america
perseverance um
speaking out and speaking your mind and
taking a stance on things
and not um i like the saying what you
put up with is what you stand for
and that's a high bar she has built this
empire or tiny empire i would say in
verona wisconsin
epic has around 10 800 employees and
the entire company revolves around this
campus which
has i mean it's hard to describe
people have compared it to an adult
disney world
but there are just crazy buildings and
um all these different themes like alice
in wonderland
and the wizard of oz and uh
tom harry potter there's a great hall
people who know judy all have the same
thing to say
and the first thing that everyone says
regardless of whether
they like judy or their critic of judy
is that she's brilliant
that was the word i heard over and over
again she
originally coded everything herself she
had
you know a real understanding of the
fundamentals and what the company was
building
and that is part of the success of epic
as it's grown is that they build
every all of the software in-house thing
about healthcare is it is so
slow moving um and so
epic and everybody else they have time
to figure out what's next
but it definitely is an exciting moment
um
for the industry judy doesn't talk
publicly that much she has this like
very
mythical uh status like if you're in
healthcare circles if you say the name
judy
everyone knows who you're talking about
you don't have to say judy faulkner
i asked judy what it's like to be one of
the few women leaders in software
and her answer was that she just doesn't
think about it that much
she's just a person doing work and
that's how she approaches it she told me
that
as long as she's effective and bringing
value to the company that
she will keep being ceo and
so i think she's just gonna keep working